jedes bild eines schwarzen lochs dass du
je gesehen hast ist fake ob simulationen
von wissenschaftlern oder gar ganz aus
interstellar diese bilder sind leider
alle nicht echt es sind lediglich
animation und von dem was wir denken wie
ein schwarzes loch aussehen könnte
aber das hat sich heute geändert heute
am 10 april 2009 10 wurde das aller
erste echte bild eines schwarzen lochs
veröffentlicht und wie die
internationale gruppe an
wissenschaftlern das geschafft hat das
erkläre ich euch heute
[Musik]
vor über 100 jahren hat albert einstein
seine allgemeine relativitätstheorie
veröffentlicht seitdem konnten viele
wissenschaftler dazu beitragen einsteins
theorie zu bestätigen
aber eine seiner vorhersagen schwarze
löcher konnte bisher nicht direkt
beobachtet werden
schwarze löcher wirken eine so große
gravitationskraft aus dass sie die raum
zeit um sich herum stark krümmen
lichtstrahlen in ihrer umgebung werden
gebogen und ab einem bestimmten punkt
dem ereignishorizont sogar zurück zum
schwarzen loch geführt kein licht das
auf ein schwarzes loch trifft kann
jemals wieder entkommen aber wie
fotografiert man etwas das per
definition unsichtbar ist
nun wir machen uns den selben trick zu
nutzen den fotografen schon seit jahren
für schöne fotos verwenden wir
fotografieren nicht das objekt selber
sondern das licht dass es blockiert die
silhouette um das schwarze loch und den
ereignishorizont herum kreis nämlich
eine menge heißes plasma das im
radiowellen spektrum gut sichtbar ist
dieses klassement hüllt sich quasi um
das schwarze loch herum und wir können
so die form und größe des schwarzen noch
selber erkennen wenn ein stein recht
hatte dann müssten wir auf dem foto das
erkennen können was wir durch modelle
und simulationen bereits erwarten
ok also einfach ein radioteleskop auf
das schwarze loch richten und damit
sollten wir ein schönes bild bekommen
oder
nun ganz so einfach ist es leider nicht
denn das schwarze loch ist trotz seiner
riesigen masse von uns aus gesehen
extrem klein im vergleich zu anderen
astronomischen objekten am himmel ist
das geradezu winzig stellt euch einen
apfel vor der auf der 384 1400 kilometer
entfernten mondoberfläche liegt und ihr
wollt von diesem schönen apfel ein
hochauflösendes foto machen
das sind die relationen mit denen die
forscher hier arbeiten müssen um zu
verstehen warum ein foto mit einem
normalen radioteleskops sogar
physikalisch unmöglich ist ist diese
formel hier wichtig durch die beugung
der wellen muss ein teleskop größer
werden
je kleiner das objekt ist dass wir
beobachten wollen und um das schwarze
loch zu fotografieren das kann man recht
einfach ausrechnen müsste unser teleskop
so groß sein wie die erde
dass das nicht wirklich realistisch ist
ist klar
deswegen kommt hier das event horizon
teleskop ins spiel
das ist nämlich eigentlich nicht eins
sondern ganz viele teleskope die überall
auf der erde verteilt sind
diese technik wird als very long
baseline interferometrie oder auch
langen basis interferometrie bezeichnet
zusammen haben sie den nötigen
durchmesser um das schwarze loch
abzubilden klar sind das nur einige
wenige punkte einer riesigen fläche aber
durch ein paar clevere tricks können die
wissenschaftler auf die fehlenden
informationen schließen
einer dieser tricks ist die rotation der
erde aus zu nutzen
ein anderer ist ein rhythmus der sich
alle bilder ansieht die zu den
gesammelten informationen passen könnten
und die unwahrscheinlichen ergebnisse
herausfiltert dieser prozess ist
unglaublich aufwendig und einer der
gründe warum die 36 institutionen aus
europa asien afrika und amerika so lange
gebraucht haben um ein bild zu
produzieren ursprünglich aufgenommen
wurden die daten nämlich bereits im
april 2017
zehn tage lang haben sich die teleskope
damals das schwarze loch angeschaut doch
alleine alle daten ungefähr 27 petabyte
oder 27 millionen gigabyte von der
ganzen welt an einen ort zu bekommen hat
monate gedauert
keine internetverbindung dieser welt
kann so viele daten transportieren und
so haben die wissenschaftler
letztendlich viele hunderte festplatten
mit daten in flugzeuge geladen und
verschickt eine station die am südpol
musste dabei mehrere monate warten denn
in der zeit von märz bis september
fliegen dort keine regulären flüge da es
monat lang dunkel ist
alle daten wurden zusammen mit exakten
uhrzeiten von atomuhren aufgenommen so
dass sie später synchronisiert werden
konnten
und auch dieser prozess dauerte einige
zeit denn mehrere teams arbeitet
unabhängig voneinander um fehler zu
vermeiden und ein möglichst offenes
ergebnis zu bekommen
andernfalls könnte es sein dass die
wissenschaftler einsteins theorie
bestätigen weil sie nur diese im kopf
haben und alle anderen hinweise
verwerfen wie eine wissenschaftlerin des
teams sagte wir wollen für die
möglichkeit offen sein einen elefanten
im zentrum der milchstraße zu finden
und um euch nicht länger auf die folter
zu spannen hier ist es endlich okay ein
sehr unscharfe roter kreis im ersten
moment etwas enttäuschend das muss ich
zugeben aber wenn man sich mal klarmacht
wie viel planung und arbeit in diesem
bild steckt dann ist es wirklich
beeindruckend
zum ersten mal können wir ein schwarzes
loch direkt beobachten und seine masse
und größe messen und was wir hier auf
dem bild sehen bestätigt mal wieder die
relativitätstheorie es stimmt nämlich
unheimlich genau mit unseren vermutungen
und simulationen von schwarzen löchern
über ein einstein behält also weiterhin
recht wir können auf dem bild auch die
akkretionsscheibe also die masse an
heißen plasma die sich um das schwarze
loch herum dreht sehen und durch mehrere
aufnahmen an mehreren tagen erkennen
dass sie sich im uhrzeigersinn dreht und
wir können schließen dass der jet also
der materie strahlt in das schwarze loch
abstrahlt in unsere richtung zeit und
das war erst der anfang die
wissenschaftler rund um das event
horizon teleskop werden weiterhin
beobachtungen an stellen daten auswerten
und das teleskop verbessern
als nächstes soll ein bild vom schwarzen
loch im zentrum unserer galaxie gemacht
werden
das heißt sagittarius a sternen und wenn
es soweit ist dann erfahrt ihr das
garantiert auf meinen social media
kanälen links dazu unten in der video
beschreibung wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr
zum aktuellen eigenes hören wollt dann
schaut euch das video von klicks nun zu
diesem thema an
christoph berichte schon seit 2017 über
das projekt und hat genau wie ich diesen
tag entgegengefiebert
sein video könnt ihr hier sehen viel
spaß dabei und ansonsten ein großes
dankeschön an meine page eon unterstütze
die mir bei diesem video geholfen haben
und danke an euch fürs zuschauen wie
immer bleibt neugierig patrick
[Musik]